>> JOINING ME NOW IS FORMER
TRUMP NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
JOHN BOLTON.
AMBASSADOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US.
THIS IS OUR FIRST CHANCE TO TALK
TO YOU SINCE A LOT OF THIS NEW
INFORMATION HAS COME OUT.
THERE ARE TRUMP INSIDERS WHO SAY
THERE WAS A STANDING ORDER TO
DECLASSIFY INFORMATION THAT THE
PRESIDENT TOOK FROM THE OVAL
OFFICE.
YOU WERE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER FOR 17 MONTHS.
WHAT WAS YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF ANY
STANDING ORDER?
>> THERE WAS NO STANDING ORDER.
I WAS NOT BRIEFED ON ANYTHING
LIKE THAT WHEN I STARTED AS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER, I
NEVER HEARD OF IT, NEVER SAW IT
IN OPERATION, NEVER KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT IT, THE PRESIDENT
NEVER SAID ANYTHING TO ME DURING
17 MONTHS THERE.
I JUST THINK IT IS A COMPLETE
FICTION.
LOOK, THE PRESIDENT SAID HE HAD
TO TAKE CLASSIFIED MATERIALS TO
HIS RESIDENCE.
AND THEREFORE HE DECLASSIFIED
THEM BY DOING THAT.
LOOK, NOBODY'S WORRIED ABOUT
UNAUTHORIZED PEOPLE IN THE
RESIDENCE QUARTERS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
IF THERE ARE UNAUTHORIZED PEOPLE
THERE, WE HAVE GOT A PROBLEM A
LOT MORE SERIOUS THAN DOCUMENTS
BEING COMPROMISED.
MOREOVER, IF THIS EXISTED, THERE
HAD TO BE SOME WAY TO
MEMORIALIZE IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL HAD TO
WRITE IT DOWN.
OTHERWISE, HOW WOULD PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE GOVERNMENT KNOW
WHAT TO DECLASSIFY.
YOU DON'T DECLASSIFY A DOCUMENT
JUST AS TO DONALD TRUMP.
IF A DOCUMENT IS DECLASSIFIED,
IT IS DECLASSIFIED.
AND NO SUCH RECORD KEEPING
SYSTEM EXISTED AND I THINK THIS
IS JUST A SIGN OF HOW WORRIED
THE PRESIDENT'S ADVISERS ARE
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE PROBLEM
HE'S IN RIGHT NEW.
>> A FICTION YOU CALLED IT.
>> YEAH.
LOOK.
IT'S -- IF HE HAS DECLASSIFIED
HUNDREDS, MAYBE THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS THAT HE TOOK TO THE
RESIDENCE BECAUSE HE WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS AT NIGHT AS WE ALL
KNOW, OVER FOUR YEARS, THE MEDIA
SHOULD BE FILING FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT REQUESTS FOR ALL
DOCUMENTS DECLASSIFIED BY DONALD
TRUMP PURSUANT TO THIS STANDING
ORDER.
I'D LOVE TO SEE WHAT GETS
PRODUCED.
>> AND WE KNOW FROM SEEING THE
RECEIPT OF ITEMS TAKEN FROM
MAR-A-LAGO THAT THERE WAS A BOX
LABELED AS SCI, SENSITIVE
COMPARTMENTED INFORMATION.
CAN YOU THINK OF ANY REASON A
FORMER PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE SENSITIVE COMPARTMENTED
INFORMATION IN HIS RESIDENCE?
>> NO, LOOK, IN A NORMAL
ADMINISTRATION A PRESIDENT IS
QUITE LIKELY TO WRITE MEMOIRS,
HE'LL WANT AND DESERVES ACCESS
TO HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, ARRANGEMENTS ARE
MADE FOR FORMER PRESIDENTS AND
INDEED FOR FORMER CABINET
OFFICERS WHO LEAVE UNDER HAPPY
CIRCUMSTANCES, THAT SCIFS ARE
SET UP THAT THEY CAN GO TO AND
LOOK AT THIS CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
EXPLANATION THAT CARRIES ANY
WEIGHT WHATEVER, WHY TRUMP JUST
DIDN'T FOLLOW THE NORMAL
PROCEDURES, EXCEPT HE THOUGHT HE
WASN'T SUBJECTED TO PROCEDURES.
>> WE NOW HAVE SEEN THIS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RESPONSE
IN A FILING TO AN EFFORT BY
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS TO GET A
HOLD OF THIS AFFIDAVIT THAT LED
TO THE SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO.
AND IN THIS DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE RESPONSE FIGHTING IT,
THEY SAY THAT THERE IS HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL IN THE
AFFIDAVIT, THEY ALSO SAY
DISCLOSURE OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
AFFIDAVIT AT THIS STAGE WOULD
ALSO LIKELY CHILL FUTURE
COOPERATION BY WITNESSES WHOSE
ASSISTANCE MAY BE SOUGHT AS THIS
INVESTIGATION PROGRESSES AS WELL
AS IN OTHER HIGH PROFILE
INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU WORKED ON SORT OF BOTH SIDES
OF THIS, AMBASSADOR, INSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND INSIDE
THE SECURITY WORLD.
HOW DO YOU READ THIS FILING?
>> WELL, I THINK IT SAYS THERE
ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
HERE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND
MANY OF HIS ADVISERS POST
PRESIDENCY.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE GOT TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE LEGAL
BATTLE THAT IS GOING ON AND THE
POLITICAL BATTLE.
I THINK THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
POSITION SOUNDS PERFECTLY
REASONABLE ON THE LEGAL BATTLE,
BUT ON THE POLITICAL BATTLE, I
THINK THEY'RE BEING OVERWHELMED
BY DONALD TRUMP.
IF WE WERE IN A COLISEUM WITH
TWO GLADIATORS, ONE OF THEM
DONALD TRUMP, THE OTHER MERRICK
GARLAND, WE WOULD BE ABOUT TO
WITNESS THE SLAUGHTER OF THE
LANDS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
UNDERSTANDABLY WANTS TO FOLLOW
ITS NORMAL PROCEDURES.
IT IS FACE AN AD AN ADVERSARY W
COULDN'T CARE LESS ABOUT NORMAL
PROCEDURES.
KNOW IT IS HARD, BUT THEY'RE
NOT DOING ENOUGH TO EXPLAIN WHY
THIS SEARCH WARRANT WAS EXECUTED
AND WHY NOW THEY DON'T WANT TO
RELEASE THE AFFIDAVIT.
LAST NIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN
THEY FILED THEIR MOTION THEY
SHOULD HAVE PUT SOMEBODY ON
CAMERA AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE READING FROM IT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TWEETED IT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE SENT IT TO
EVERY MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
I'M NOT ASKING THEM TO SAY MORE
THAN WHAT THEY HAVE SAID IN
THEIR COURT FILING, BUT THEY
HAVE GOT TO DO MORE TO EXPLAIN
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO AND THEY GOT
TO THINK OF CREATIVE WAYS TO
JUSTIFY IT TO A VERY SKEPTICAL
PUBLIC IN MANY RESPECTS.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING BETTER PR,
BUT ARE YOU SAYING THEY SHOULD
RELEASE THE AFFIDAVIT, PARTS OF
THE AFFIDAVIT OR LET MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS SEE SOME OF THE
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL?
WHAT IS YOUR VIEW ON THAT?
>> LOOK, THE ARGUMENT IS THAT
YOU CAN'T EVEN RELEASE A
REDACTED VERSION OF THE
AFFIDAVIT BECAUSE MOST OF IT
WOULD BE REDACTED.
I'M NOT SURPRISED BY THAT.
I CAN'T -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
DOCUMENTS ARE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SENSITIVE
SOURCES THEY HAVE SPOKEN TO.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT YOU'VE GOT
TO BE MORE REALISTIC ABOUT THE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY'RE OPERATING UNDER.
I WOULD SAY THIS, I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING IF PRESIDENT BIDEN
THINKS THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION, HE NEEDS TO SAY
SOMETHING.
OTHER POLITICIANS NEED TO WEIGH
IN.
OTHERWISE TO PICK A WATERGATE
METAPHOR, RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
TWISTING SLOWLY, SLOWLY IN THE
WIND.
IT IS A TARGET FOR DONALD TRUMP
AND IT IS NOT BEING DEFENDED.
>> IN YOUR BOOK, YOU REFER TO
FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI AS A SWAMP CREATURE.
AND I DON'T THINK YOU MEANT THAT
AS A TERM OF ENDEARMENT.
AND FIONA HILL TESTIFIED OF RUDY
GIULIANI, YOU SAID THAT HE IS A
HAND GRENADE THAT IS GOING TO
BLOW EVERYTHING UP.
THAT WAS IN RELATION TO THE
SITUATION WITH THE CALL TO
UKRAINE.
AMBASSADOR, HOW SURPRISED ARE
YOU TO SEE THE FORMER NEW YORK
CITY MAYOR NOW AS A TARGET OF AN
INVESTIGATION IN GEORGIA?
>> WELL, I HAVE TO SAY, I'M VERY
SADDENED BY THAT THIS.
I'M SADDENED THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED TO RUDY GIULIANI AND I
THINK IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
OTHER PEOPLE, BUT IT TELLS ME
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY BE
RIGHT BEHIND HIM IN TERMS OF
LIABILITY.
IF RUDY IS IN TROUBLE AS THE
TARGET OF AN INVESTIGATION, I
THINK TRUMP ALMOST CERTAINLY IS
AS WELL.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
IRAN, IF I CAN, FOR A SECOND
HERE.
ON FRIDAY, AUTHOR SALMAN RUSHDIE
STABBED, HE'S RECOVERING,
THANKFULLY, THIS MORNING, BUT
WITH LIFE CHANGING INJURIES.
IRAN HAS DENIED ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE STABBING
ATTACK ON FRIDAY, BUT IN SOME
WAYS HAS CELEBRATED IT.
YOU WERE THE TARGET OF AN
IRANIAN ASSASSINATION OPERATION.
THERE WAS MONEY OFFERED TO KILL
YOU.
WHAT DOES THIS SAY ABOUT IRAN
AND HOW IT OPERATES TODAY, ITS
SENSE OF IMPUNITY AND WHERE IT
IS ON THE WORLD STAGE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S THE
CRITICAL QUESTION WHEN WE COME
TO A RANGE OF ISSUES INCLUDING
IRAN'S GENERAL SUPPORT FOR
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY ITS PURSUIT
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, LIKE
FOLLOWING THE HOLY GRAIL, MADE
CONCESSIONS FOR THE LAST 17
MONTHS TO WORM ITS WAY BACK INTO
THE DEAL, A BAD DEAL TO BEGIN
WITH.
THIS SAY REGIME FOR WHICH
COMMITMENTS MEAN ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
THEY'RE PREPARED TO MAKE A LOT
OF COMMITMENTS TO BREAK FREE OF
THE ECONOMIC SANCTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPOSED SINCE THE U.S.
WITHDREW FROM THE DEAL, AND TO
GET BACK MONEY THAT HAS BEEN
FROZEN.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SLOW THEIR
NUCLEAR PROGRAM DOWN IN THE
SLIGHTEST AND I THINK REALLY
WHEN CONGRESS COMES BACK AFTER
LABOR DAY, PEOPLE NEED TO TELL
THE ADMINISTRATION YOU ARE
PURSUING A DANGEROUS PATH FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
THESE ASSASSINATION PLOTS
AGAINST AN IRANIAN AMERICAN
HUMAN RIGHTS ADVOCATE IN NEW
YORK, SALMAN RUSHDIE, NOT JUST
AGAINST ME, BUT MARK ESPER,
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO AND MANY OTHER PEOPLE
SHOW THE IRANIANS THINK THEY CAN
PROCEED WITH IMPUNITY.
AND UNTIL WE DEMONSTRATE TO THE
CONTRARY, THINK A LOT MORE
PEOPLE WILL BE VULNERABLE AS
WELL.
>> AMBASSADOR JOHN BOLTON, WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME, SIR.